did an irl stream in london as well oh
you did it during [ __ ] jubilee
weekend yeah
that like that looked like hell man yeah
i was i was filming with chris uh at um
westminster bridge and it was just like
you couldn't move yeah like it was so
busy because everyone was waiting
because it wasn't the only thing that
was happening that day was the jets and
stuff were flying yeah yeah which was
kind of cool like the jets flew over in
the formation of 70. right like a
stupid amount of jets i'm like is this
where our military powers go okay
and then they did the [ __ ] red white
and blue not american uk uh all that
[ __ ] came over it was just crazy it
was just so busy could not get phone
signal anywhere because it was just so
many people were there it was really
cool i got a view through like a shitty
bridge because i i we were stopping to
try and set up my irl bag yeah we could
not get signal anywhere to start the
stream
uh but yeah cause like there was just so
many people right it was cool it was
like one of those things you're like i
was actually in like the right place at
the right time to see this thing happen
yeah yeah yeah um and so i i finally
managed to find a spot like three or
four miles away from where we originally
were going to start yeah
where it was like okay the signal is
kind of okay yeah let's just [ __ ]
start it yeah and my laptop is in my
hotel room connected to the internet and
i press go live and it's like one
kilobyte and uh one megabyte sorry and
for twitch you need about six it can
work on three to four but it's it's
sketch yeah and i had one and i was like
[ __ ] and we've already started we
already spent like an hour prepping and
i was like
[ __ ] and then i see and you know that
funny thing where when your pc is
connected to wi-fi and internet yeah for
some reason they'll be like
uh sorry uh it was connected to wi-fi
and ethernet yeah so i was like yeah
let's use the wi-fi yeah
i like the wi-fi it's kind of it's kind
of sick like it's wireless and it's like
no no no no use the [ __ ] why would
you use the slower one when you're
connected to the first one i'm sure
there's some [ __ ] engineer in the
comments like oh actually it's because
uh
i'll be like i don't [ __ ] care
to me it just doesn't make sense right
so on my i'm on remote access with my
[ __ ] phone i'm like trying to like
zoom in click the wi-fi thing turn off
the wi-fi and then suddenly it's all
working perfectly yeah we go live and we
[ __ ] around in london it was great it
was really fun you know we you know
chris is probably the happiest i've ever
seen him in the uk bro chris seemed like
he was in his head bro he was in like
cloud nine
i'm so glad to be back i just want to go
to a pod i want to have fish and chips
mashed pies i don't [ __ ] know my man
was like cleaning up english breakfast
i think i think he was doing like the
english breakfast tour of the uk yeah
i'm gonna try it here i'm gonna try it
here i'm gonna try it here man was
unstoppable it was great time though
it's it's so interesting just seeing the
dichotomy of like chris doing an irl
stream with you in japan versus in the
uk yeah in japan he's just like you know
just don't talk too loud i don't want to
be a [ __ ] yeah i feel like in japan
i have to be the one who's like yeah
we're going to do this we're going to do
this
in the uk because it's like let's
[ __ ] go here let's do this get out of
the
it way just so fun like it was great it
was great i didn't get to hang out with
chris before because yeah yeah i was
like i was like stacked every day oh
yeah of course obviously i mean yeah you
have so much [ __ ] yeah yeah then you had
to like you know entourage the uh the
american family and show them around
make sure they weren't in trouble yeah
yeah yeah i mean it was it was a very
very interest uh interesting experience
showing them around uh because like the
first night uh they you know they just
flown in
um and
so they didn't want to go too far but we
went to like my local pub which is
literally like down the road right but
it's like so it's it's like not in like
central central brighton it's like we're
like on the outskirts of brighton
whatever so it's it's not somewhere you
see like
a lot of like touristy people go right
because brighton's like a pretty famous
touristy place uh and i remember we go
there
and
we sit down we're having a pint and
obviously they're american and they got
like the true
british experience right right it was it
was a local pub
and we had
local people there and
some some younger people
uh recognized their accents
oh my god
were they like road men or something
yeah yeah yeah
and i've never seen like you know you
know there's always like the image of
how americans think british people speak
and like for the first time sydney's
family got like the true british
experience right right right they they
got true local brits and i remember they
were having like they were like
there was one kid having a conversation
with sydney's brother and
and of course he was talking about his
[ __ ] rap career that was that was
going to take off in new w in america
because he had listeners from new york
and he had like a spotify account yeah
and i could i could see sydney's
brother's face just like i know you're
speaking english
but i have a no idea what the [ __ ] you
are saying
it was literally like a scene out of the
in-betweeners right like yeah maylene's
husband marky had the exact same
experience when i like took him to a
friend's house yeah yeah yeah and like
my because my friends in london they're
not originally from london they're from
like further up north right so they have
the more northerner accent and uh and
one of my friends yusuf uh he has like a
really strong leeds accent right which
is like
hard even for me yeah yeah to understand
sometimes so it was just [ __ ]
hilarious every time uh
yusuf like opened his mouth
and just said something yeah just monkey
would just like
squint like this like he's like really
trying to [ __ ] close his subtitles
he's like this is definitely english
i think
i don't know and every time yusuf would
stop talking i would turn to maki in
japanese i'd be like did you understand
that he was like no
and then he got really sad and he was
like i thought i was good at english
but i guess i'm not and i'm like don't
worry don't worry about it it's fine
this is like this is like even i have
trouble with this thing yeah that should
be on like the toeic exam it should be
like can you understand a man from leeds
if you can you're fluent right yeah
pretty much you're good to go yeah
it's funny because like if the the more
northern you go the harder time it gets
for like anyone outside of the uk to
understand what the [ __ ] is being said
exactly yeah because even for me as like
a southerner i can barely understand
what's being said in like liverpool oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah being from
the north that's like you just
understand everyone yeah it's great i'm
like yeah super chill it's all good
lucky the only time i struggle is like i
think there's a really uh i felt ashamed
at this one point there's i think
there's a clip of a really really rural
irish uh pub and then they interviewed
is that the guy with like the three
teeth i think so and he just [ __ ]
says [ __ ] and i remember thinking
i was like and even at that point i'm
like i only understood like three words
it's like the guy from kalani or
something it might be something but like
that was the only time where i'm like
yeah i don't even know if if the other
people in the pub understood him
i don't know if i'm the one
but the interviewer understood him
because he's from that point oh that's
right yeah so he was like he the guy
would just be like there
and be like yes i like this pub too
you're conversing with this guy on the
phone yeah i wish i understood that that
was anytime i felt like inadequate i was
like yeah i thought i understood
everything everything [ __ ]
yeah i know the exact video you're
talking about as well because like i i
felt disappointed as well because i'm
like i'm like i'm sure i can understand
this i'm sure i can understand this yeah
[Music]
i don't know you just start uh you you
like start playing in like 0.5 speeding
like maybe i can like gauge the system
close the closed captions just say
[ __ ] i don't know yeah
i don't even think the closed captioning
can determine if it's english or not i
wish it was like a tv ad one so they'd
have to have that like woman who like uh
does the uh
sign language the sign language she's
trying to do the shot like
she's just like
i give up dude
i don't give a [ __ ]
do they have like strong accents in
wales like to the point where
maybe nothing you wouldn't be able to
understand just a very like oh i'm from
this village you know you were talking
is there like differing like
geographical differences in wales like
the uk or is it kind of just like um
yeah stronger or weaker i generally like
the more north uh
west you go uh i had to [ __ ] do the
thing yeah uh it gets a little stronger
the south has a different accent but
it's not like completely i wouldn't say
it's that different but they also have
different words yeah so i feel like the
difference is not so much in the dialect
more so in uh well not the dialect is
the written word yeah the accent isn't
as different just the words yeah so the
accent sounds very similar with both but
you get the more traditional welsh
accent that you might hear in movies and
stuff from the south yeah so
it's more of a dialect difference than a
pronunciation yeah yeah the dialect's
pretty similar i mean it's basically
like translation
yeah so so it's like japan yeah yeah i
mean it's because it's like the the
[ __ ] history is so uh different
between the north and the south because
yeah the south was like conquered by
england for a really long time and then
north wasn't so yeah it's way more welsh
up north and then it's it's you [ __ ]
know you've watched villain saga
just like
they lightly touch it a little bit i'm
jealous because australia doesn't have
that at all and i always thought it was
really cool because like you know
american like the uk it's like oh you
can immediately tell where someone is
from yeah yeah yeah but in australia we
don't have that at all yeah i really
love the history of it but like no one
gives a [ __ ] so it's really boring to
talk about it and i i don't want to talk
about it if people are like they're like
[ __ ] resident sleeper like
[Music]
it's like yeah but vividly it's pretty
good i think it's super fun
it doesn't really cover it yeah yeah
it's cool that it at least touches upon
it yeah yeah yeah exactly it's weird
it's a [ __ ] mess it's pretty cool
though at least you got an anime
surrounding around and right now right
yeah and you got one of them
you've got england but at least we had
escalades
badass characters in all of anime man
we got is [ __ ] five minutes in a
hetalia episode
uh you got rin from free
yeah oh wow
bro he's an australian brother literally
the worst character he [ __ ] tears it
up in the water to be fair when i did
watch the free movie and i saw sydney
station i was like yeah [ __ ] yes let's
go let's go
i think the most representation i've had
is just like one guy from yuri on ice
and that's that's it that was that no
what about the chaon movie that was set
in the uk right now i'm talking about
thailand thailand oh thailand yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like we had one thai ice
skater in yuri and ice and i remember
when i went to like there's like a big
anime chain in japan called like animate
yeah so we have an animate in bangkok
and like they had like the [ __ ]
there was just like this one cardboard
cutout of that one thai ice skater from
yuri or nice i don't know it's just like
we did it boys
let's go
this is kind of lucky one of the most
badass anime characters as well that's
pretty cool yeah he's definitely up
there and not because he's well that
might have bumped him up a few weeks we
just got like racially profiled by
hetalia character
like that wasn't even accurate and then
he was in one episode and he never came
back got an entire account well didn't
even get one yeah every no every other
country got it yeah except wales
apparently whales didn't get it they
were like what are they [ __ ] doing
well
this is it again i've said i've said
this a billion times what else is a
branding problem we need a brand new
the person in charge of welsh branding i
don't know who it is prime minister i
don't know needs to [ __ ] sort this
out we need to we need to have a game
plan of how we're going to brand what's
there in wells
see that's the thing what am i going to
tell you like oh do you like history
great well there's loads but if not like
go eat some [ __ ] sheep that's great
if you like lamb it's amazing we also
have some pretty good baked stuff like
yeah we have a lot of welsh cakes that's
kind of good but i mean that's that's
yeah because like because like to me
like nature's yeah i've been to like
ireland and i'm like i [ __ ] love
ireland like yeah it's like one of the
most aesthetic places i've ever been to
like felix went to wales he loved it he
went to uh abbott street no i think it
was one of them
yeah yeah really cool looking place that
was inspired by like mediterranean
things yeah weirdly and like the west of
wales yeah it's a really cool idea he
sold me on wales yeah there's a lot of
really cool areas it's just like you
can't like you can't just rock up yeah
like if you
if you just rock up without researching
where to go yeah you're gonna be like
where the f where the [ __ ] is everything
what is there to do like where am i if
you know what you're going for there's
some amazing hiking spots really
beautiful nature parks
like a lot of the north brecken beacons
area is all like nature reserves like
nothing's built there it's just just go
hike having a great time a broken
briefcase is really good yeah yeah yeah
um and uh yeah snowdonia uh snowden
slowdown
that sounds like a place from like game
of thrones yeah that's like a pokemon
series
i mean chris has been up here yeah it's
good uh there's yeah there's a bunch of
cool seaside stuff that you can go to
but like yeah it depends yeah yeah you
really have to research because like
when you hear about people visiting the
uk obviously there is like english
ireland yeah yeah and people are like oh
i [ __ ] love going to ireland because
like every [ __ ] fifth person here in
america is apparently like
like half irish or some [ __ ] right but
then you also hear people talking about
like yes scotland
i think it really helps for the the uk
countries like okay you have london and
then you can branch out you have
scotland then you can branch out you've
got dublin then you can branch out it's
like you have card
even then cardiff is really far from all
the nature stuff like yeah it's kind of
weird in the in wales where if you want
to kind of travel
via public transport up north you have
to go around and back up you don't you
don't go you can't just go through the
middle so if you go if you've got that
there's like a lot of mountains or uh
yeah there's a lot of mountains and it
didn't make sense to build the trains
there because it kind of connects
through england right and it goes back
in just like shrewsbury and stuff yeah
uh so if you go really far west and it's
going on off and on it's kind of really
annoying to get back up so if you're
going westward you plan your whole trip
to go west and then you go back right
it's kind of annoying to go back up like
you can if you want to go to like
aberdeen but that's no abuse is down
south we're saying no no abba tower
there's so many fights
it's all it's all weird it's a really
cool place if you plan your trip it'll
be cool i still have a great town yeah
this again there's some amazing stuff
you got to show us around because like
i've never had like a guide for whales
yes basically you have to bear in mind
my my experience of wales was when i was
like young and a kid so i'm just
like show me whales and i'm like
show you yeah but i'm going to be like
that for australia yeah yes sir like
like my view of sydney is going to be
very different
the average tourism yeah i think because
all my tourism was done in the confines
of like school trips and stuff yeah it's
like very like warped yeah what i
actually would think would be fun my
parents know that my parents love doing
it they they like they're doing this
thing where they go all around whales
like by walking right not in one go it's
like in trips right right so they do a
section and then they go back and then
they do another section they go back
it's cool it's [ __ ] insane
my parents love walking yeah and
exercising i wish that rubbed off on me
it's like where's the
bare minimum of wanting to walk and
stuff yeah but uh yeah if you if you're
interested in like really convoluted and
complex history yeah you might want to
look into it it's kind of cool yeah it's
just about people trying to not be taken
over by the english for like 400 years
like pretty much every country on in
like the uk right i think they did a
pretty good job look at the rest of the
world they didn't last very long against
england i think we did pretty good uh we
had a pretty good run
pretty it's pretty
good oh yeah but i mean it's cool
there's some really funny history
moments of i think i've ever told that
i've taught that story before about the
castle like it took over yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i [ __ ] love that
story yeah it's so [ __ ] funny i wish
we had like fun stories like that yeah
like we don't know we didn't have any of
that [ __ ] yeah we're just like yeah a
bunch of convicts was just like [ __ ] you
uk and then we just started our own
country and uh yeah just a whole lot of
uh racism and politics yeah yeah
it's it's like it's because
sydney's family were visiting like you
take for granted just how much history
the uk has yeah because you could you
could show that like i i was showing
them just like even just like seeing
even them just seeing like buildings
yeah pubs that were just like really old
that that's like fast that was like
fascinating yeah many churches in the uk
have been around since uh over 1 400
years yeah like there's a lot of
churches that are still like built in
800. like this is just insane yeah
they're still there it's crazy and it's
like we take for granted just having
like a country with like history in it
whereas like i think if you're like over
25 or something in america then you've
like been alive for like a tenth of the
entire country's history yeah
your entire country's age and that's
like [ __ ] that just [ __ ] blows my
mind you know yeah
that there's a country that that is that
young but then you get you run into the
issue of like okay i want to learn about
uk history where do i start and then you
go with the highlights but then when you
start digging into stuff you're like
this is really [ __ ] convoluted right
okay so they took over and then another
guy took over and then another guy took
over and then england got taken over by
vikings and then now it's the french
yeah it's convoluted but it's super
[ __ ] fascinating if you're into that
[ __ ] right that's what makes it even
cooler that all like some of these
churches and stuff have lasted like
being taken over like 10 different times
yeah right like it's like how the [ __ ]
did this it's the exact same thing with
like japanese history as well yeah and
that's what makes it so fascinating for
history like fanatics right but it's
like you know [ __ ] yeah australia's not
even 250 years old yeah we [ __ ] were
founded in
1777 i think 78 yeah we're just like
[ __ ] like the uk had like already
figured this [ __ ] out
we were just like oh what the [ __ ] do we
do like a lot of modern like a lot of
countries that we know today and we're
like super used to like i'm very new
yeah i think finland is only like 100
years old yeah oh germany yeah yeah like
to think that germany like was like like
a completely different [ __ ] thing
yeah like because we've been alive a
whole lot i mean our whole life is like
angela merkel like it's so weird when
you're like these countries are not like
they weren't a thing yeah yeah i don't
think germany want to talk about that
yeah
yeah
be ashamed